The general good experience,
here's how so,
so I've got just about been open for
nine years with CSA.
We had zero members when we started.
I've got about $1,300,
which was the motivation.
What made you the motivation was that I
spent.
It was always a passion.
I was doing martial arts when I was a
child that was fighting.
I just wasn't making money doing it and
then I got into that other life and did
that for about 15 years and I was being
paid to protect people that could afford
it but maybe didn't deserve it for a
very long time.
And unfortunately that's the way it
works is if you can afford it,
you probably don't deserve it.
That's a funny way of looking at.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's a,
it's a true way of looking at it because
I was doing it at the highest level,
you know,
I wasn't doing security work at the
kids' choice awards,
standing Jim Carey for two hours saying
I'm Jim Carey's bodyguard.
Right.
So it's one of those things where I saw
it at the very highest level and it
just,
it turned me off after awhile because
you know,
you're just,
you're,
you're being a babysitter to people who
have money.
Even with the biggest threats from Iraq,
Afghanistan,
a Haiti run down the list.
It wasn't about helping people and I was
wanting to help people.
So I get it.
When I,
when I opened the gym,
that was the goal was to help people and
it,
it turned into that gym.
And this is why I feel that our gym
model is successful is because tonight
at 5:30 during a boxing class,
my professional fighters are going to be
in class with everyone else.
There's no protein,
only practice.
Everybody trains together.
Everybody works together.
The model is for people.
You want to get in shape,
wonderful.
You're going to get into shape.
You want to have stress relief.
Wonderful.
You want to become a fighter?
I don't have a fight team practice try
out or any of that.
You come to the gym,
you put in the work,
you support the team,
you trained side by side with world
champions,
you get better,
you have a good time.
It's a huge family gym.
It's a huge family environment and the
mixture of the self defense and the
fighting and the fitness one doesn't
need the other.
So unlike like an Aka and I love hobby,
but the gym is about the fighters.
Fighters lose.
That's a fight.
People go out the back door,
right?
For me,
I kind of a fight or lose,
my membership's not going to matter,
but people are still gonna come,
they're still going to train,
they're still gonna support.
They're still going to buy tickets and
that's been the recipe.
And because the gym is that way,
it's allowed me to have this model where
I don't charge pro fighters.
You're remarkably normal.
Oh,
thanks.
I know people restricted at how normal I
am.
Just like,
wow.
Really?
I think my reputation through maze,
a famous child,
that's a very unusual maze.
Uh,
yeah.
my life is unique to me.
That's what I like to say.
And uh,
I'm almost got peerless person,
like to a certain extent,
there's not too many people I can look
left and right.
And we,
you know,
I,
like,
we have similar experiences.
Is there anybody that you ever
contacted,
like Jodie foster or someone who's made
it through and seems pretty put
together?
Not really,
no,
not really.
I mean,
it's kind of a weird cold call,
you know?
Hey,
Jodie foster,
such a small clan people,
like if a comic called me that I knew
they wanted to talk to me,
I would talk to them because it's such a
small club of people.
I mean we do have our weekly therapy
sessions.
Yeah.
You know me,
Elijah Wood,
Jodie Foster,
you know.
Yeah.
Like we all get together and yeah,
we,
we've actually,
we do primal screaming.
That's what we do.
I was describing what it was like.
I have a friend who,
uh,
Ricky Schroder who uh,
is,
um,
you know,
obviously it was a very famous when he
was young as well.
And one of my favorite theme songs,
TV theme songs of all time.
And I was saying like you,
the way you developed is not like the
way the recipe calls,
like the recipe calls for you to have a
childhood and try to figure out life and
then become a man and trying to find
yourself and then try to find your path.
And by the time you he became a man,
he was already famous.
And the same thing with you.
You were already famous as you were
developing and learning.
Yeah.
I don't know exactly how to like kind of
even describe it because it's always the
way my life has been kind of thing in
the same way that like a lot of kids,
like,
you know,
they'd go out and they catch bugs and
play sandlot baseball or whatever.
You just look at it like that's the way
it is.
Like you don't really realize how unique
the whole situation is until you have
perspective because you have nothing to
compare it to really other than I guess
tv shows and movies and things like
that.
So I knew that my upbringing was unique,
you know?
I knew it knew it was different,
but at the same time it's kind of just,
it's not until you get some perspective,
some life experience,
but until you really realize that,
oh wait,
this,
this was particularly.
Yeah.
Weird.
So you brought up an interesting what
would leopold and
leopold this disciple,
you know,
father of modern wildlife ecology,
started the first program of Wildlife
Ecology at University of Wisconsin in
the 19 forties,
populations of deer in the northern part
of Wisconsin.
We're growing by leaps and bounds and
they were dramatically changing the
landscape,
you know,
denuding the landscape,
eating eastern white cedar and deer in
northern latitudes tend to yard together
in the wintertime.
And so leopold knew that this was,
you know,
deleterious to the longterm viability of
that ecosystem.
He took people out,
landowners out hunters out into these
deer yards in the spring to show them
how there was nothing to eat within
reach of a deer on its hind feet.
And there were bodies of dead deer that
had stopped through the wintertime in
order to demonstrate to them the
consequences of mismanagement if deer
hurts.
So he and he was a real proponent of
showing people the results of doing
things the wrong way and education.
So I think yeah,
it comes back.
So what we're trying to do,
not saying that yeah,
we're leopold in or anything like that,
but education,
getting information out,
getting accurate information out.
It's maybe one of the biggest things we
can do.
Like no one ever feels like they're
anything special and you always like if
there were any good they don't know.
And you always ruthlessly self critical
and trying to get better.
I mean I've worked with big actors,
big,
Big Rock Stars and the big rockstars,
like one big rockstar once one time said
to me,
I opened.
He said,
is there anyone out there?
I said,
ah,
like 19,000 people smell the wd 40.
That's how they got the last thousand
people in.
Are you kidding?
He said,
I'm always worried that no one's going
to show up.
I said,
when was that ever been your problem?
He said,
well,
never,
but who is this?
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Who's this one of my favorite people.
He's a.
So He's another guy.
He's honest,
how many people have those
were like in some Floridian,
mega done.
Hopefully won't be anyone other than
him.
Oh No,
no,
no.
And he goes out there and the place goes
nuts to show is great of course.
And I said,
you worry about people don't show up.
I get really depressed.
And I went,
okay.
And you know what?
I did the beacon theater once many years
ago in New York.
Beautiful Room.
Loved that place.
I was,
uh,
a few days later I was at mtv doing
something with like Matt Pinfield or
somebody that was living in New York and
I'm leaving.
And the courtesy lady,
she said,
Hey,
George Carlin is in the green room and
he wants to meet you.
And I went,
wait a minute,
dumb question.
The George Carlin,
because I've been listening to that guy
since I was an eighth grade class clown
and occupation fool actually came out
for me to go to the record store.
They were not nice price records.
They were what was on.
That's how old I am memorized.
And by eighth grade of course.
And I said,
George Carlin wants to meet me.
Okay,
walk in,
and there's George Carlin,
he's there to promote his next hbo thing
and he's going to do like,
like multiple nights at the beacon
theater place.
I would never sell out.
He's going to do a month or whatever.
And he said,
Hey,
I'm.
I said,
Mr Carlos [inaudible].
I'm George.
I'm like,
wow.
He said,
Oh,
you did a book signing the other night
at tower records?
I said,
yeah.
He goes,
oh man.
It was so cool.
I was in line for like half an hour and
finally I got so cold.
I went home.
I said,
you waited in line to meet me?
He's like,
yeah.
I'm like,
why don't you just walk in like,
oh,
I can't do that man.
And
he said,
so you just at the beacon?
I said,
yeah.
It was amazing.
He said,
did they get the jokes?
I said,
oh,
that's not really what I do.
I said,
I'm sorry,
what do you mean?
He goes,
like,
Dee Dee Dee,
can you get to the audience from that
stage?
I said,
it's actually a pretty big place.
It's a lot his feet to before the first
row I said,
yeah.
I said,
you're George Carlin.
I think you're going to do okay.
But he was sincerely wondering like,
is it going to be okay in there?
I'm like,
are you kidding?
You were handcuffed with lenny bruce in
the back of a cop car and you're asking
me if it's going to be okay.
Was He handcuffed?
Yeah,
it's that great book.
A great book.
Uh,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Lenny Bruce,
Alex Jones cannot now go,
well,
just go to the other youtube.
There isn't another residential.
You Hey,
just go to the other facebook.
There isn't another.
So we have to recognize that the way we
are organized as a society that the town
square is now owned by corporations who
that need to be regulated.
Right?
Like before,
if you know when 18 t was the phone
carrier for everybody,
they couldn't go.
I'm not going to give Alex Jones a phone
service because I don't like the Shit
shitty saying.
So you know,
we,
you can't deny services somebody,
all that stuff.
Just that's not really a valid
comparison because the phone service
wasn't distributed information to
people,
right?
The phone service is just a method of
communication.
It was just a utility.
What he's able to do through info wars
is if you've got them on your platform,
he's going to say some things and he's
going to use your platform to say some
things that you know,
might not be true.
It might be crazy.
So you've got to decide like when does
it become a problem?
And I think where they drew the line
with Sandy Hook.
So here's what I say,
Joe,
uh,
we need to treat these as public
utilities because they are right
facebook,
there is no alternative.
There is an alternative to youtube.
We need to regulate them.
Well,
it's a long overdue by the way.
And they are monopolies where there's
obvious to everyone that they're
monopolies.
But you know,
when you,
when you invent something called
whatsapp and then facebook buys it for
$20,
billion dollars,
there's a monopoly,
there's no way.
There's no way to,
to compete with these people.
So these are monopolies.
They need to be regulated and people's
need to be protected and it it,
it.
That's how.
That's where we need to go because right
now we're leaving it up to the whims of
a billion.
Like you'd say,
Hey,
if Alex Jones really did some shit that
was wrong and he should be taken off,
or his free speech should be a bridge
for it,
do it.
Let's do it.
Go,
go to a court or go to a thing or go.
People go,
well,
he docks his people and he did it is if
doxing is illegal,
he should be prosecuted.
If that's what happened,
but you shouldn't take away.
Did he docs people?
That's what they're saying.
They're saying he's done.
He'd wanted he docs people from newtown
or whatever from the school shooting,
so that's what they're talking about.
The individuals that he gave their
addresses and their names.
That's what they are saying,
that he decay,
but let's find out if he actually did
that because that sounds crazy.
I,
I'm,
I don't know if he did,
but we did not saying what he actually
did.
This is what's crazy.
I keep hearing that he promoted the idea
that sandy hook was a false,
it was false and that it was a false
flag and that these were all actors.
I don't know if he actually said that.
I think what he actually said was,
I don't know if that happened.
I think that's what he actually said.
People are saying,
well,
that's promoting the idea that it was a
hoax,
but I want to know if that's what he
really said.
See,
I don't know if that's even the case
because I've heard it.
I've heard it written that he promoted
the idea that sandy hook was a
conspiracy,
but I did not quoting.
When they say that there's no quotes,
there's no.
Sandy Hook was a hoax.
Those kids were actors.
Those kids are not dead.
I don't see that anywhere.
Right,
but they keep attributing that to him
without quotation.
But again,
if this.
If there was some kind of process due
process where you could go back and look
at the transcript.
I know this.
Not only that,
if during this whole time where he's
being tried,
he was still labeled to be on youtube
and have his videos,
he could show in his videos that he
didn't say that he could show what he
actually said and tell you what he
actually said and show clips.
He can't do that anymore.
So now the narrative is completely in
the hands of the mainstream media.
One hundred percent.
So the Alex Jones narrative is being
taken 100 percent out of his hands and
now it's in the mainstream media.
And now there's sandy hook deniers,
conspiracy theorists,
right wing lunatic,
all these different things.
Which mayor,
if some of it.
I mean Alex,
my fucking nuts.